[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur les chaînes parlementaires pour
suivre la clôture du congrès du modem le
parti de françois bayrou réunis depuis
hier dans le 14e arrondissement de paris
et dans quelques minutes
nous suivrons en direct le discours de
françois bayrou réélu hier sans grande
surprise président du parti françois
bayrou qui devrait s'exprimer aux
alentours de 11h30
et pour suivre et analyser ce discours
trois invités sur ce plateau le
politologue olivier rouquan bonjour
merci d'être avec nous anita aux serbes
ont sans doute merci d'être là vous êtes
éditorialistes chez atlantico et puis
notre éditorialiste politique ludovic
aux beaux jours ludovic merci à tous les
trois dette sur ce plateau et sur place
dans le 14e arrondissement de paris pour
nous faire vivre les coulisses et les
réactions politiques on retrouve tout de
suite
rabhi cas bonjour rabhi alors je le
disais en le discours de françois bayrou
va débuter dans quelques minutes que
peut-on attendre de ce discours de
françois bayrou rabbit oui alors la
salle des conférences du marriott est
déjà remplie il ya environ 600 personnes
hier christophe castaner le premier
ministre edouard philippe se sont
exprimées aujourd'hui c'est au tour de
françois bayrou de venir s'exprimer
il a été élu hier à près de 94% des voix
à la tête de son parti
il devrait s'exprimer pendant un peu
plus d'une heure et devrait fixer un cap
pour la suite du quinquennat et mettre
en avant les priorités du mouvement sur
les réformes institutionnelles ou encore
sur le volet social pour rappel françois
bayrou avait interpellé le président de
la république récemment sur la nécessité
de l'affirmation d'un nouvel d'un
nouveau modèle social pour la france une
façon aussi pour le président du modem
de se singulariser d'exister face à
cette majorité la république en marche
écrasante avec deux ministres au
gouvernement et 47 députés le parti
centriste n'a jamais été aussi puissant
mais paradoxalement ils peinent à se
faire entendre alors bien sûr il y a eu
cette loi sur la moralisation de la vie
publique mais on constate que peu
d'amendements sont retenus et qu'ils ne
sont pas souvent entendue comme ça a été
le cas sur la réforme
de l'iace f alors ce qu'on peut tout de
même retenir c'est que le modem arrive à
faire émerger des thématiques sociales
dans le débat comme ce projet de loi sur
la résidence alternée des enfants en cas
de séparation des parents
et puis bien sûr il y a l'europe qui
sera au coeur de cette matinée avec
l'échéance des prochaines élections
européennes
ir christophe castaner a appelé le modem
à faire une alliance est à construire
autour de deux parties une liste ouverte
pour les prochaines élections
européennes de 2019 merci beaucoup rabhi
on vous retrouve bien sûr un tout au
long de cette édition spéciale le
discours de françois bayrou attendue
dans quelques minutes et regarder sur
ces images
c'est actuellement marielle de sarnez la
vice présidente du parti qui est à la
tribune françois bayrou qui devrait donc
suivre d'ici quelques instants alors
ludovic on entendait un radis à
l'instant dire le modèle n'a jamais été
aussi puissant mais pour autant pas
est-il vraiment le modem alors il pèse
le modem c'est la deuxième force de la
majorité avec 40 47 députés et donc il
pèse numériquement après ce que le modem
est décisif pour faire adopter les lois
du gouvernement évidemment non puisque
avec plus de 300 députés la république
en marche est assez hégémonique au sein
de l'assemblée nationale et en même
temps c'est vrai que le modem essaye un
pur pour montrer qu'il a une forme de
valeur ajoutée qu'il n'est pas seulement
un supplétif de la république en marché
essaye de faire surgir un certain nombre
de thématiques on va le voir sans doute
avec françois bayrou tout à l'heure qui
va essayer sans doute de jouer un peu
les monsieur plus sur une ligne
peut-être un petit peu plus social sur
sur l'europe sur la réforme
institutionnelle et puis un enfant ou
modems pèsera malgré tout y compris
numériquement justement c'est au moment
où emmanuel macron tentera de faire
voter sa réforme institutionnelle au
parlement par par le congrès et la les
47 députés du modem et puis les
sénateurs également pèseront
effectivement de tout leur poids on va
revenir sur cette réforme et olivier
rouquan comment on peut faire le modèle
pour être une composante de la majorité
présidentielle ce qu'il est et à la fois
affirmer sa singularité
oui la voix est assez étroite puisqu'on
le voit un puisque comme il a été
rappelé
les propositions pour l'instant fait par
le modem sur le plan législatif ont été
barrés par la république en marche et
parfois avec peu de considération ils
s'en plaignent les députés modèle donc
la voie est étroite aussi parce qu'on
voit que l'autre parti centriste udf
pour l'instant plus d'élus locaux et la
suite ce sont des élections locales que
le modem est en plein travail voire est
en train de se déchirer on pourrait dire
or si le modem fait trop entendre sa
différence et jeunes la république en
marche il est clair que le président
pourrait construire notre parti sur
saône elle alors son triste gauche on
sait pas trop à partir des descentes de
l'udf avec également quelques
constructif et le modem se retrouverait
alors l'a pris en étau donc le modem il
la voix est très étroite pour faire
entendre on va dire une voie originale
pour l'instant manita les vielles disais
à l'instant
la voix est très étroite et oui parce
que le sens politique pour le modem
aujourd'hui pour le modem sans doute
mais le centre est l'espace le plus
disputé actuellement 10e à lui d y est
allé constructif et puis il ya le modem
les députés modem ont été élus avec
l'étiquette la république en marche
c'était la république en marche modem
c'est à dire que la l'élan qui on a vu
au mois de juin
ils le doivent à emmanuel macron alors
on dirait qu emmanuel macron doit doit
son élan à françois bayrou
donc c'est dû prêter pour du rendu le
modem on n'existe qu'en distinguant
aujourd'hui la majorité c'est à dire la
république en marche est encore assez
homogène les les sujets qui vend vont
arriver bon le premier est annoncé avec
les propositions sur l'immigration la
salle ça va effectivement grincer parce
que on va voir les la tendance de gauche
se distinguer de la tendance de droite
au sein de la république en marche mais
l'espace politique pour le modem est
difficile c'est surtout en terme de
place et donc ils ont intérêt à
consolider leur nombre d'élus ça va être
le cas sans doute pour les élections
européennes et pour les élections
locales et bien je pense qu'ils sont
condamnés à faire acquis
avec la république ans avec la sq est en
train de se profiler mais c'est vrai que
le paysage au centre est complètement
mort cela parce que c'est un peu le jeu
des 7 familles avec des responsables il
se distingue au mieux avec des
différences de fond au pire sur des sur
des questions de personnes
quelqu'un lui dit jean christophe
lagarde hervé morin et les centristes
qui prennent leur autonomie par rapport
à lui des îles et radicaux qui sont
réunifiées mais déjà il ya de la
dissidence agir de franck riester dont
on ne sait pas encore quelle est
exactement la force de frappe et serait
donc que françois bayrou en tout cas les
le modem qui doit qui doit beaucoup à
l'élection de d'emmanuel macron mais
vous le disiez anita emmanuel macron qui
doit aussi son élan pendant la campagne
présidentielle en partie au moins grâce
à françois bayrou
finalement le modem même s'il n'est pas
très audible aujourd'hui est la
principale force au centre
en tout cas au parlement parce que c'est
vrai que dans les collectivités locales
lui dit pour l'instant pèse plus mais
justement c'est le pari de françois
bayrou c'est aux européennes et aux
élections locales
finalement d'avoir une sorte d'alliance
d'alliance avec la république en marche
on verra si la république en marche il
ya intérêt mais c'est ce que tu es en
train de se profiler notamment pour les
européennes
parce que françois bayrou a bien
conscience que le défi d'après ces de
renaître au niveau électoral notamment
au niveau local a juste on va écouter
parce qu' edouard philippe le premier
ministre 1 étaient présents hier à ce
congrès du modem et il a dit venez dire
ludovic et bien il a rappelé
l'importance de ce parti du modem dans
la majorité présidentielle en écoute le
premier ministre il n'est pas je crois
interdit il serait bien malvenu de
passer sous silence
un élément qui m'apparaît clairement à
l'heure où je vous parle c'est que le
modem que tu président pierre françois
et pour le gouvernement un partenaire de
tous les instants utile fiable et
inventif un partenaire exigeant en privé
et solidaire en public ce qui je ne vous
le cache pas est assez préférable à
linverse
[Applaudissements]
nour et d'un philippin le modem est un
partenaire exigeant en privé c'est à
dire qu'ils font entendre leur voix
quand même oui ils négocient en douce
c'est ça que vous voulez dire
enfin c'est ça que vous allez lire et à
felip le modem aïe aujourd'hui à une
valeur ajoutée à l'assemblée parce que
la plupart des députés modem avait était
d aider des élus locaux ou étaient des
cadres du parti et donc ils sont pires
est plus efficace dans la discussion
parlementaire que ne sont les députés la
république en marche parce que
finalement il y en a assez peu qui est
qui émergent pour le moment dans le
débat parlementaire proprement dit alors
qu'ils sont 308 et ne me demandez pas de
les récifs de le réciter leur leur
demande pas les devis vous demande vous
suivez vous ces travaux parlementaires à
l'assemblée est ce que ces 47 députés du
modem il pèse vraiment dans les trésors
dont le dixième de leurs effectivement
pour l'instant le bedaine de ne pèse pas
vraiment et y compris au sein de la
république en marchandant dans le groupe
majoritaire
certains estiment que voilà il faut
faire attention de ne pas maltraiter
justement le modem parce que encore une
fois
pour l'instant tout va bien ou presque
pour emmanuel macron qui remonte dans
les sondages
les lois passent facilement à
l'assemblée nationale et au parlement
plus plus généralement mais on ne sait
pas comment on peut peut tourner le
quinquennat et ça peut être une force
d'appoint intéressante au fil du
quinquennal modem et puis encore une
fois il ya en ligne de mire cette
réforme institutionnelle qui arrive
hélas toutes les voix compteront y
compris bien sûr celle celles du modem
et donc on voit bien dans les propos
d'edouard philippe et du gouvernement
d'ailleurs parce que hier il y avait
outre edouard philippe 1 5 membres du
gouvernement dont jean michel blanquer
air dont christophe castaner est un peu
de calinothérapie dans les propos
d'edouard philippe oublier aussi que
françois bayrou et marielle de sarnez
d'ailleurs font partie du comité de la
majorité qui a été mis en place par
paris par philippe pour piloter un petit
peu justement cette majorité et la
politique du gouvernement
donc on voit bien que l'exécutif fait
attention à françois bayrou au modem de
vie qu'on va aller tout de suite
indirecte du caire de cette salle du 14e
arrondissement de paris où françois
bayrou vient tout juste de monter à la
tribune on va suivre son discours en
direct en 70 degrés ça a été dit du de
notre dixième anniversaire en tant que
mouvement démocrate
ce congrès n'est pas un aboutissement
c'est un commencement et je suis très
fier d'avoir mené tous ses combats
pendant 10 ans et de pouvoir aujourd'hui
vous présenter cette équipe qui s'est
exprimé tout au long de ces deux jours
cette équipe qui est formé de ceux qui
ont pris la responsabilité des grands
choix que nous avons fait ils viennent
de s'exprimer ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
la voix de notre mouvement à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat au parlement européen
quel que soit 100 parlementaires et
former cette équipe aussi de vous vous
qui avez participé au congrès vous les
milliers de militants qui nous écoutent
peut-être à l'instant des engagés des
citoyens engagés des responsables
civique qui ont montré l'idée qu'ils
avaient de l'avenir et qui ont montré
quelque chose d'encore plus important
marianne le disais à l'instant que on
peut avoir un idéal
et faire entrer cet idéal dans la
réalité on a pris l'habitude au travers
du temps ceux qui s'intéressent aux
mouvements politiques de croire que il
ya des idéaux dans un ciel lointain et
que la réalité elle est au contraire
fait de de demi-mesure de reculade et
d'arrangements pas toujours brillant pas
toujours présentable et nous nous avons
montré exactement le contraire et peut
avoir l'idéal et s'appuyer sur 7 sur cet
idéal pour changer la réalité pour
changer le monde
permettez-moi de le dire c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour nous mais sans vouloir
exagérer c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
tous ceux qui croient à la démocratie en
france et peut-être à la démocratie même
au delà de nos frontières et c'est ce
que vous avez fait part cet engagement
qui ne s'est jamais démenti
qui n'a jamais faibli et qui s'est au
contraire affirmé avec l'idée que nous
nous pouvions aller plus loin que
beaucoup ne croyaient que nous pouvions
aller
donc ce congrès a montré cette équipe a
montré cette force et il a montré que
cette force était ouverte
j'étais très heureux qu alain juppé nous
ait envoyé un message au début du
congrès j'étais très heureux que le
gouvernement cheikh jacqueline cher
geneviève soit là en en force et en
puissance
j'ai beaucoup aimé le discours des
doigts philippe hier et beaucoup parmi
vous l'ont fait et peut-être on peut lui
dire par nos applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
et j'étais très heureux que pierre
moscovici en tant que parlementaires
européens avec les différences de
parcours
pardon en tant que commissaire européen
maxima autant que le commissaire
européen français avec les différences
de parcours qui sont les nôtres viennent
ce matin pour nous dire ce que nous
avions de plus précieux en commun et qui
nous unissait est donc une force pour la
reconstruction du pays et une force
ouverte et il n'y a pas beaucoup de
formations politiques qui peuvent
affirmer cela qui peuvent affirmer cela
jean louis bourlanges qui est là bas a
dit hier quelque chose d'absolument
important pour moi essentiel nous sommes
une force aujourd'hui
mais en vérité nous sommes une force
parce que nous avons un patrimoine une
vision une histoire
nous savons d'où nous venons et car
chacune des époques de cette histoire
nous avons des inspirateurs alors ils
sont pas là physiquement ce que la vue
change les choses mais ils sont là par
la pensée par la volonté permettez moi
de dire que ce qui de notre famille
politique je pense à robert schumann
on construit l'union européenne
aujourd'hui la communauté européenne et
sont là pour nous ils sont là et je
disais hier que comment se sentir
étranger à ceux de notre famille
politique
presque seul dans la vie politique
française ont su dire non aux accords de
munich le jour des accords de munich
ça n'est pas du passé et ça n'est pas de
l'histoire et cette phrase absolument
admirable de celui qui était le jeune
éditorialiste de ce petit journal qui
s'appelait l'aube qui sera plus tard
président du conseil national de la
résistance qui s'appelait georges
bidault et je sais très bien que par la
suite beaucoup de choix nous ont opposés
mais cette phrase admirable au terme de
son éditorial dans l'aube le jour des
accords de munich
il finit son éditorial hilare sarah
moins de 30 ans finit son éditorial à
part cette phrase formidable il dit
lorsqu'il s'agit de dire non le meilleur
moment c'est le premier
congrès commencement je veux vous dire
ceci
le congrès s'est tous les trois ans donc
je me reporte par la pensée à 2014 je me
reporte je me porte par la pensée à 2020
mais point n'est besoin de remonter si
loin il ya un an
à cette même date qui aurait dit que
nous allions vivre ce que nous avons
vécu bien je peux vous dire que les
choix successifs que nous avons été
amenés à faire les aventures incroyables
de la démocratie française ont fait que
aujourd'hui quelque chose a changé en
profondeur
pas seulement dans notre équilibre
politique mais dans l'image de que la
france assume vis-à-vis d'elle-même et
vis-à-vis du monde
vous vous souvenez tous je suis sûr de
cette admirable chansons de barbara
qu'elle a d'ailleurs regretté paraît-il
quelques années après l'avoir chantée
parce que l'histoire c'est comme ça
mais elle a dit quelque chose a changé
c'est indéfinissable et j'ai le
sentiment aujourd'hui que quelque chose
a changé
qui peut parfaitement être définies dans
le dans le climat de la démocratie en
france
dans le climat de la vie civique dans
notre pays qu'est ce qui a changé au des
choses très simples premièrement il ya
un an tout le monde en france et en
europe et au delà de nos frontières
avait le sentiment que la france était
précisément le creuset du pessimisme et
des rejets
si on avait fait une enquête en europe
et peut-être au-delà de l'europe il ya
un an
beaucoup de citoyens beaucoup
d'observateurs beaucoup de penseurs
avait le sentiment que
peut-être en france il était possible
que le pire se produise c'est à dire la
victoire de l'exclusion le rejet de
l'idée européenne le renforcement le
renforcent leur enfermement de la france
sur elle-même et l'organisation de la
division entre français tessa que que le
monde voyait en où il se trouve que
c'est exactement le contraire qui s'est
produit
produit par l'engagement de centaines
d'abord de milliers après 2 millions
ensuite de citoyens qui ont voulu
adhérer à un autre projet j'écrivais
dans dans le livre que je consacrais au
mois de janvier 2017
al'approche des élections
présidentielles j'écrivais il ya un
moment où les peuples se lasse de la
lassitude
elle même je sentais monter cette cette
fontaine la cette jouvence là je sentais
qu une sève venait et cette sève ces
manuels nous traquerons qui en a été le
porteur et le défenseur devant les
français jusqu'à la victoire
alors nous nous sommes venus en soutien
bien sûr parce que nous avons identifié
le risque et il était important bien sûr
parce que dans les propos les idées la
vision d' emmanuel macron nous avons
reconnu notre projet parce que c'est
notre projet disent-ils mais c'est le
nôtre aussi
et donc que nous nous sommes engagés et
nous nous sommes engagés avec
enthousiasme avec efficacité sans que
dans nos rangs quelles qu'aient été les
les analyses préalables des uns et des
autres les convictions préalable des uns
et des autres sans que dans nos rangs
une seule réserve s'exprime à l'égard du
choix que nous avions fait mais cela
vient aussi de la personnalité du
nouveau président de la république et je
veux le dire ici parce que nous sommes
quelques-uns à croire au contraire de ce
que les pessimistes nous ont enseigné au
travers du temps sommes quelques-uns à
croire que c'est les hommes qui font
l'histoire est étrange parce qu'on est
depuis longtemps habitués à cette idée
que au fond c'est l'économie qui décide
de tout c'est des mouvements profonds
mondiaux eh bien nous avons vérifié en
2010 est que ce sont les hommes qu il
arrive que ce soit les sommes qu'ils
fassent l'histoire emmanuel vaincrons
avec sa jeunesse avec l' enthousiasme
qu'il a su focaliser avec quelque chose
qui n'est pas souvent dit et que je veux
dire devant vous avec la liberté
d'esprit qui est la sienne avec
l'originalité d'approché de penser et
l'audace
- qu'on en puisse dire c'est qu'il n'a
pas manqué pendant l'année 2010 est il a
su faire naître un monde nouveau nous
sommes heureux de les avoir aidés mais
il est juste de dire que c'est lui par
son élan par sa volonté par son anti
conformisme qui a réussi à faire un
autre monde nouveau et je crois que
c'est une gratitude que nous devons
exprimer à son emploi
il était dépeint par un grand nombre
d'acteurs et d'observateurs et par nous
aussi quelquefois comme un homme du
moule du moule du pouvoir en france
et bien ce que nous avons vérifié
pendant l'année et ce que je vérifie
tous les jours et ce que je veux dire
spécialement moins c'est qu'il n'est pas
prisonnier du moule et que c'est pour ça
qu'il est en capacité de porter
d'entraîner et au bout du compte de
changer la situation du pays
par exemple ce n'était pas être
prisonnier du moule et des habitudes que
de nommer un premier ministre qui venait
précisément du parti le plus opposés à
la vision que lui-même président et lui
portait eh bien c'était un bon choix et
nous avons vérifié que edouard philippe
avec ses idées ses convictions sa
liberté d'esprit lui aussi la montre et
puis son style manière d'être
parce que moi je crois savez il ya une
vieille expression française qui dès le
style c'est l'homme un style c'est la
politique aussi une manière non
agressive et non dupes non agressive et
en même temps pas dupes de ce que
portait avec l'humour qui fait qu'on se
met en question soi même et avec
l'ironie qu'il faut quand on veut mordre
et bien tout ça cette manière de mener
l'équipe gouvernementale tout ça répond
à la promesse implicite qui était celle
de la compagne d'emmanuelle macron et
pour nous c'est une fierté de soutenir
et de participer
[Applaudissements]
alors nous avions vécu pendant des mois
et des mois dans le scepticisme général
autour de la proposition que nous
faisions de changer la majorité du pays
pas seulement d'obtenir une alternance
mais comme nous le disions à l'époque
d'obtenir la grande alternance pas
seulement l'alternance qui vise à
remplacer un corps par l'autre mais
l'alternance qui vise à remplacer les
deux camps en même temps au pouvoir
le nombre de ceux je dis ça avec une
toute petite délectation le nombre de
ceux qui nous ont expliqué que les
institutions de la vème république et en
ce qu'elle était il était impossible
qu'un homme du centre qu'un homme de 2,2
ce terreau centrale du pays soit élu
président de la république il y avait
beaucoup de raisons de le penser puisque
nous mêmes nous avions échoué dans cette
bataille là que c'était impossible et
que en tout cas si jamais il arrivait
que cette élection fut acquise alors on
pouvait être certain d'une chose il ne
pouvait pas avoir de majorité
comment auriez-vous une majorité
disait-il vous n'avez aucun sortant
eh bien nous avons montré de quoi ceux
qui n'ont aucune sorte en sont capables
lorsque les peuples veulent que les
choses changent
et vous voyez si l'on fait des additions
depuis 20 ans jamais l'addition de d2
force principale qui exerçait ensemble
le monopole du pouvoir dans notre pays
jamais l'addition de ces deux forces
n'avaient eu moins de quatre ou cinq
cents députés à l'assemblée nationale
bien cette fois ci ils sont à 130
députés à moins de 130 députés ces deux
forces là c'est dire la dimension de
l'événement qui a eu lieu
l'effondrement de ses deux tours
jumelles du monopole français et le
surgissement d'une force nouvelle
puissante original pas encore tout à
fait organiser et il faut que tout le
monde y travaille pour pour que la
démocratie se renouvelle de l'intérieur
c'est une manière de se souvenir que
ceux qui ont voulu le quinquennat pour
l'élection présidentielle et le
rétablissement du calendrier républicain
que la présidentielle précède de
législatives alors que d'autres
voulaient que les législatives le
précède de la présidentielle ce
rétablissement du calendrier républicain
qui écarte et ce que j'appelais à
l'époque le calendrier dingo a permis
que la vague de changement porté par
l'élection présidentielle que cette
vague de changements emporte toutes les
digues pour obtenir le paysage nouveau
que la démocratie française mérite des
essais une logique
et c'est une stratégie et c'est un blanc
et je suis très heureux que nous l'ayons
portée
[Applaudissements]
alors pourquoi haut parce qu'il ya une
chose que tout le monde ou presque tout
le monde billets qui est une chose qui
était une chose pour nous d'évidence
c'est qu' il n'y avait en france une
majorité cohérente possible une c'était
la majorité centrale et que les autres
qui nous disaient mais il faut une
majorité ou de droite ou de gauche pour
qu'elle soit cohérente
en réalité il mentait hills aveuglé
eux-mêmes pour les plus honnêtes vous
essayez de nous aveugler pour les autres
parce que les deux majorités latéral on
a vérifié dix fois depuis 20 ans qu'elle
était totalement incohérente fracturé
qu'elles étaient entre les extrêmes de
chaque camp et les modérés de chaque
thon pas d'unité à droite pas de
cohérence à droite
pas d'unité à gauche pas de cohérence à
gauche il n'y avait qu'une cohérence
possible
c'était la grande majorité centrale
l'arc central comme nous disions que
nous avons finalement imposé dans la vie
politique du pays
pour une raison profonde et vous allez
retrouver des accents qui étaient les
nôtres
pendant toutes ces années là c'est qu'en
réalité sur le fond sur les options
majeures
nous pensons la même chose ceux qui
étaient sur les deux rives de cette vie
politique artificiel en réalité ils
veulent la même chose
ils veulent une vieille que de mick
restaurer rétabli réhabiliter revivifier
et ils veulent que cette vie économique
soit hausse que cette vitalité
économique soit au service d'un projet
social c'est à dire j'y reviendrai dans
la suite du discours que que nous
portions un modèle pour nous et pour le
monde et ils savent bien que si l'on
veut vraiment affronté cette question du
changement en profondeur
si l'on veut avoir une politique de
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
si on veut avoir une politique de
défense si on veut avoir une politique
d'environnement jan alors il est
nécessaire que se construise une europe
qui soit pas seulement une institution
mais une démocratie au service des
citoyens
et donc c'est la première fois depuis
deux décennies qu'il y à une majorité
qui est fondée sur un accord profond la
majorité centrale du pays celle que nous
avons construite
c'est la seule majorité cohérente et les
majorités latéral je les appelle comme
sa majorité d'un bord ou de l'autre sont
totalement incohérente
nous avons rendu à la vie politique
française la vertu essentielle qui est
de mener une politique avec une
cohérence dans la pensée et dans
l'action
[Applaudissements]
et je voudrais vous dire que ce
mouvement-là de reconstruction ils
comptent éminemment pour les français
marielle la 10e ce qui est frappant
c'est que sept mois après l'élection
présidentielle
je dirais je vais avancer une
proposition probablement hardy
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a plus de
français qui espère le succès d'
emmanuel macron et de ceux qui
l'entourent qu'il y en avait le jour du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
ce jour là les gens votaient parce
qu'ils pensaient que c'était pas
possible
il y avait dans ce vote un refus d'un
danger d'un risque et d'une insuffisance
qu'ils avaient clairement identifiés
mais aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose
d'autre
oh pas partout pas dans tous les milieux
pas dans toutes les sensibilités
mais ça monte il y à chaque jour un peu
plus de français qui espère que le
travail entrepris par emmanuel macron
est déjà accompli en partie réussie pour
le pays réussissent pour leurs enfants
et ça n'est pas le moindre des succès
que nous avons remportés en 2017
mais cet espoir la 7e cette aurore là
sur la vie politique il est important
pour nous français mais il est important
pour le monde
nous étions avec quelques-uns d'entre
nous avec marielle avec jean-louis avec
jacqueline avec jeunes viennent nous
étions avec frédéric nous étions au
sommet du parti démocrate européen à
rome parti démocrate européen dont que
nous avons fondé avec romano prodi
quelques années et qui est présidée par
francesco rutelli et par moi-même
il y avait là des délégations de tous
les pays européens et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que dans chacun des
sujets abordés dans chacun de ces sujets
il y avait l'expression de l'espoir
qu'emmanuel macron faisait naître au
delà de nos frontières faisait naître en
europe
et si nous regardons cela alors nous
apercevons quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important pour nous tous et
pour la réflexion sur les choix que nous
avons fait alors nous voyons que si l'on
regarde les grands pays du monde et les
chefs d'état de ces grands pays du monde
si nos regards se tournent vers les
états unis et monsieur trump ou bien
vers la russie ou bien vers la chine ou
bien vers les zones les plus dangereuses
de la planète le moyen-orient ou vers
les pays européens
alors il ya une chose que nous pouvons
dire sans risque de nous tromper c'est
que le président de la république
française est aujourd'hui dans le monde
un des leaders les plus entraînants et
peut-être au premier rang des leaders
les plus entraînants pour faire mettre
dans la vie de l'univers politique une
force une volonté un projet qui change
les choses y compris à l'échelon
international
et si nous voyons si nous voyons ce qui
a été fait récemment au liban ce qui a
été fait dans les injonctions à la libye
ce qui est fait dans le l'affirmation
d'une proposition face à monsieur trump
qui soit une proposition de fidélité à
la défense de notre patrimoine naturel à
la lutte contre le changement climatique
alors on voit que la bonne nouvelle pour
les français a été aussi une bonne
nouvelle pour beaucoup de démocrates
dans le monde
beaucoup de gens qui espèrent qu'un jour
ou l'autre les citoyens du monde vont
reprendre la main sur leur propre destin
[Applaudissements]
et donc dans cet espoir là
le président de la république et ceux
qui l'entourent vos gouvernements une
immense responsabilité mais nous avons
nous aussi une responsabilité éminente
nous comme citoyen comme force politique
parce que j'ai toujours affirmé que la
responsabilité de l'avenir d'un pays
appartenait évidemment aux gouvernants
mais n'appartenez pas seulement aux
gouvernants et même appartenait à la
majorité mais n'appartenez pas seulement
à la majorité et que nous avions tous
une coresponsabilité dans l'avenir du
pays et même si on veut réfléchir
philosophiquement 30 secondes et même
que cette co responsabilité là elle est
précisément la définition de la
démocratie
nous sommes dans cette famille politique
très attaché un penseur un homme
d'engagement qui s'appelait marc
sangnier et marc sangnier a donné de la
démocratie une définition que je veux
rappeler devant vous il a dit la
démocratie c'est l'organisation sociale
qui porte à son plus haut
la conscience et la responsabilité des
citoyens et cette conscience et cette
responsabilité
alors elle nous enjoint de participer à
l'effort de reconstruction que porte le
président de la république et le
gouvernement
alors nous voyons bien la responsabilité
qui est la nôtre
j'ai évoqué même si c'est en quelques
phrases la responsabilité de gestion le
rappel qui a été fait que nous avons été
la première famille politique française
à mettre en garde contre les déficits
extec ccif et contre l'explosion de la
dette nous donne une responsabilité pour
que cette politique continue et
s'affirme
vous avez entendu pierre moscovici
rappelé que désormais les déficits dans
la zone euro et est à était inférieure à
1% et que nous sommes nous heureusement
nous avons réussi à vivre le passage au
dessous de 3% mais qu en vérité ça ne
suffira pas parce que le seuil où la
dette n'augmente plus qui devrait être
la première étape que nous nous fixons
ce seuil la il est inférieur à 2% de
déficit
encore faut-il prendre en considération
les taux d'intérêt dont je dis c'est à
voix basse nous ne sommes pas absolument
assurer qu'il reste au niveau minimal
qu'il connaisse aujourd'hui pour la plus
grande chance de ceux qui empruntent
particulier et à 10h dit rien mais je
pense qu'une menace de cet ordre existe
et donc cette responsabilité-là qui a
été un heureusement assuré ces dernières
années par la banque centrale européenne
et je veux répéter ici
notre conviction est minoritaire pour
l'instant dans le débat politique
européen que si l'on regarde les grandes
banques centrales du monde celte ont la
responsabilité de la création de monnaie
de la lutte contre les risques
principaux qui viennent des crises
la banque centrale américaine la
constitution lui fixe deux objectifs le
premier de ces deux objectifs c'est la
lutte contre l'inflation
c'est le cas aussi pour la banque
centrale européenne mais le deuxième de
ses objectifs et j'invite comme marielle
l'a fait que l'on réfléchisse à
l'opportunité ou de voir que nous
devrions avoir d'ajouter au mandat de la
banque centrale européenne le mandat de
gestion de la monnaie pour obtenir le
plein emploi
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
les états unis sont aujourd'hui un
chômage extrêmement bas et que l'europe
demeure avec un chômage
hélas trop haut il ya aussi dans les
institutions une capacité de réponse aux
crises sociales et même familiale que
nous rencontrons donc donc centrale
objectif plein emploi autant de lutte
contre l'inflation
et c'est une chose évidemment centrale
et puis le projet économique nous le
connaissons le projet de gestion c'est
de libérer la créativité du pays de
faire en sorte que tous ceux qui ont à
l'esprit d'inventer d'adapter de créer
de faire naître des entreprises des
innovations ils puissent le faire sans
avoir le sentiment qu'une chape de plomb
d'un homme de contrôle excessif s'abat
sur eux et paralyse au fond leur volonté
de faire et de ce point de vue là les
choix du gouvernement je lui dis ont été
des choix qui méritait d'être soutenu et
que nous avons eu raison de soutenir
mais au delà de la responsabilité de
gestion il y a une perspective que je
voudrais défendre devant vous notre
responsabilité
elle n'est pas seulement d'adapter la
france réalité économique du monde ça
compte
parce que les réalités économiques du
monde elle s'impose à tous et qui
voudraient les ignorer seraient
inéluctablement gros c'est comme on dit
pour les bateaux sur sur les écueils
mais nous ne sommes pas une force
d'adaptation de la france
nous sommes une force de révélations ou
dead à la révélation du projet de
société que doit porter la france dans
ses frontières et dans le monde auprès
de ses citoyens et auprès des citoyens
du monde
je veux m'arrêter une seconde à ce point
mais bon pour nous pour moi c'est très
important
toutes les études il en est sorti encore
cette semaine plusieurs montre que le
mouvement que nous avons avec d'autres
dénoncés depuis longtemps que j'ai
appelé dans un livre qui avait fait un
peu de bruit autrefois qui s'appelait
abus de pouvoir le mouvement des
inégalités croissantes
nous vivons dans un univers dans lequel
la concentration continue des richesses
entre les mains d'un nombre toujours
plus étroit de puissance devient quelque
chose d'absolument effrayant je vais
vous donner les chiffres que cette étude
récente a indiqué il y a deux ans la
même étude indiquait que l'équivalent de
la moitié de l'équivalent de la richesse
détenue par la moitié les plus pauvres
des citoyens du monde
les richesses de 50 % des citoyens du
monde que l'équivalent de cette richesse
était détenu par soixante deux
milliardaires dans le monde et l'étude
sorti cette année indique que pour
arriver à ce seuil de richesse là il
suffit aujourd'hui de 8 milliards
r sur la planète 4 milliards 3 milliards
et demi
d'un côté d'hommes de femmes des
familles et de l'autre huit personnes et
ce mouvement va croissant et pardon de
le dire parce que je m'arrête pas du
tout aux richesses ou à l'argent je veux
aller plus loin ce mouvement-là
d'inégalités croissantes
étant donné l'état des sociétés de la
planète il retentit pas seulement sur la
voir mais retenti sur le pouvoir
ce sont les mêmes qui parce qu'ils ont
concentré les richesses réussissent à
offrir à leurs enfants à leurs
descendants
les meilleures écoles les meilleures
universités les diplômes les plus
flatteurs tout ce que le savoir permet
dans sa transmission d'offrir à des à
des générations plus jeunes et la
concentration perpétuelle de l'avoir du
pouvoir de l'influencé dans les mêmes
mains et un danger pour la société ou
pour les sociétés où qu'elle se trouve
c'est un danger pour les sociétés du
monde c'est un danger pour les sociétés
qui ont présenté hier en émergence et
dont on voit que l'écart devient
tellement insupportable qu ils menacent
même leurs exigences c'est un danger
pour le monde c'est un danger pour
l'europe
mes amis c'est un danger pour la france
nous avons la chance d'être les plus
préservés de ce mouvement là en
particulier je vais je vais citer 2
deux raisons la première c'est que chez
nous l'école est gratuite et je tiens ce
pour défendre cette gratuité y compris à
l'université et connaît des universités
de qualité qui permettent à des jeunes
venus d'autres milieux que ceux habitués
à ces pratiques soient défendus l'école
université gratuite la santé est
gratuite et donc ça s'empêche l'écart de
grandir mais d'une certaine manière
parce que nous avons développé ce modèle
là il revient à la france de montrer que
dans la proposition que dans sa logique
historique notre pays fait au monde
nous accordons autant d'importance à la
libération aux projets économiques que
nous en accordons au projet social
c'est-à-dire au projet de solidarité et
au projet d'émancipation
[Applaudissements]
la france a la responsabilité de
proposer au monde
un projet de société qui ne repose pas
seulement sur la loi du plus fort mais
qui affirme que ce que nous voulons en
même temps c'est la loi du plus juste
c'est la loi du plus juste qui est notre
raison d'être
notre raison de construire et d'avancer
la loi du plus libérateur ou
émancipateur le monde qui court vers un
gouffre d'inégalités il gagnera à savoir
qu'il ya au moins un pays un grand pays
dans le monde qui considère que son but
est au contraire un projet de justice
c'est ainsi que la france sera elle même
c'est un besoin de notre pays
alors il ya des gens qui croient que un
pays c'est une succession de générations
et à chaque génération
indépendamment de celle qui précède ses
propres visions ses propres obsessions
nous ne croyons pas je crois au c'est un
peu bizarre moi je crois que il ya dans
les peuples un inconscient comme le 20e
siècle et la psychanalyse nous ont
appris qu'ils avaient un inconscient
chez chacun d'entre nous plus chez les
hommes chez certains que chez d'autres
mais qui quitte à un inconscient dis ça
juste pour vous faire sourire
nous pensons qu'il ya un inconscient
dans les peuples commis un inconscient
dans les personnes et dans l'inconscient
du peuple français va le dire autrement
dans la mémoire immémoriale du peuple
français il ya ce besoin de porter un
projet qui ne ressemble à aucun autre
refuser un projet de soumission aux pays
les plus puissants au pays les plus
forts aux forces matérielles et de
l'argent un projet de soumission y
compris
à ce que nous voyons de plus risqués
dans la société au surgissement immédiat
que nous voyons sur les réseaux sur dans
les médias d' aucune soumission une
résistance une volonté de dire mais vous
trompez pas vous êtes forts mais nous
nous voulons construire autre chose
et ceci passe évidemment par un certain
nombre de choix que je voudrais évoquer
devant alors ses choix il existe en
politique étrangère ses choix il existe
en politique économique par exemple il
est du devoir de la france y compris en
matière de gestion de proposer une
politique de lutte contre les monopoles
ou une politique de lutte contre la
puissance toujours démultiplier des
monopoles
même si c'est bono paul sont dans des
domaines des technologies nouvelles dont
il apparaît qu'il est extrêmement
difficile de les contrôler et même
extrêmement difficile de leur parler
mais cette lutte contre les monopoles
elle est un besoin de notre pays je
crois qu'elle est un besoin d'europe et
d'ailleurs c'est très simple si nous
posons la question quel est l'instrument
politique qui nous permettra un jour de
lutter contre les monopoles si nous en
déciderons à 6 ça s'appelle l'union
européenne il n'y a pas d'autre
possibilité
[Applaudissements]
mais je veux préciser encore un peu le
projet social le projet social n'est pas
seulement un projet d'allocation pour
deux raisons la première de ces raisons
c'est que les allocations nécessaire
dans beaucoup de situations et le
gouvernement en a tenu compte puisque
sur le minimum vieillesse par exemple ou
sur l'allocation adulte handicapé par
exemple les choix du gouvernement ou sur
la taxe d'habitation entre non le
gouvernement a proposé une augmentation
de ses allocations qui sont des
allocations de solidarité de présence
auprès de ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
dans la société française mais nous
savons très bien
d'abord que de l'argent pour des
allocations
forcément il y en aura - dans l'avenir
qu'on ne croyait qu'ils en avaient dans
le passé et ceux qui disent le contraire
raconte je crois d histoire et donc nous
avons le devoir de penser différemment
le projet social de ce qui a été pas
danser dans les années précédant et il
ya une deuxième chose c'est que dans une
politique sociale qui ne seraient
fondées que sur l'idée ou le principe
des allocations il ya quelque chose
qu'on n'aperçoit pas c'est qu'il arrive
assez souvent que les allocations elle
aussi soit une dépendance surtout quand
rien n'est fait pour lutter contre cela
j'ai été très frappée à l'âme casabonne
je sais pas s'il est là
sénateur de la gironde aujourd'hui après
avoir été maire de talence pendant des
années alain cazabonne à raconter une
histoire qu'ils venaient de vivre
il y avait devant sa mairie huit jeunes
sdf et parmi ceux là on avait un avec
qui il a parlé qu'il a essayé de sortir
et c'est très simple ce garçon lui
faisait une proposition de travail
partiel
quelques centaines d'euros par semaine
quelques 500 euros par semaine et ne
pouvait pas les accès par heure par mois
excusez moi je pensais aux heures par
semaine 500 euros par mois et il n'a pas
pu accepter le travail partiel pour lui
offrait pas ce que ça lui faisait perdre
les autres allocations qu'ils recevaient
et ceci vous trompez pas c'est par
centaines de milliers que les français
sont soumis à cette des incitations là
je ne peux pas accepter le travail qu'on
me propose parce que je vais y perdre
j'ai un cas très précis en tête
la location dalle hull d'adultes
handicapés qui me permet de vivre est un
pays qui aurait cette perspective là
cette vision là alors ce pays là
probablement y chercherait à concilier
le maintien d'une partie de l'allocation
d'adulte handicapé avec l'incitation à
prendre un travail qui changerait
conditions d'existence d'un certain
nombre de ses concitoyens politique de
libération d'émancipation je veux citer
un autre exemple et c'est patrick
mignola qu'il a cité hier
l'idée que je défends devant vous c'est
une politique sociale ça doit être une
politique de libération d'un certain
nombre des déterminismes d'un certain
nombre d des écrasements qui sont
imposées aux citoyens par exemple par la
naissance par le milieu social dont on
est originaire ou culturelles par ses
origines ou le régime de ses parents ou
l'origine de sa famille
les discriminations en fonction du nom
et dicks les discriminations en fonction
du quartier de son adresse et ces
discriminations là qui s'y attaquent
je veux pas dire personne mais je veux
dire pas grand monde ce que patrick
mignola a raconté hier c'est que les
enfants d'un certain nombre de quartiers
lorsque vient le moment des stages de
troisième en entreprise je connais bien
les stèles de 3e l'entreprise c'est moi
qui les ai créé et à l'époque dans un
charivari l'idée que des enfants
pourraient découvrir une entreprise
c'était les soumettre à la logique de
l'entreprise privée et moi je pensais
que c'était une chose utile que de
découvrir le monde du travail
c'est devenu une réalité universelle
mais il ya des enfants pour qui c'est
facile de trouver des stages et ce sont
les enfants dont les parents ont
l'habitude ou peuvent décrocher le
téléphone pour appeler un copain un
artisan un chef d'entreprise un
responsable d'administration pour
obtenir un stage mais les autres ceux
qui n'ont pas les parents qui
connaissent quelqu'un
ceux qui n'ont pas le réseau cela
comment faut-il comment font-ils pour
trouver un stage
moi je crois qu'il est de la
responsabilité de la puissance publique
de conduire une politique en direction
de ceux là de s'adresser aux entreprises
en dilatant 10 ans madame monsieur le
chef d'entreprise vous avez pris quatre
stagiaires l'an dernier est-ce que vous
accepté d'en prendre six et on va vous
en présenter deux autres je suis
persuadé qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
d'administrations d'associations qui
accepterait de faire cet effort
supplémentaire à condition qu'il leur
soit garanti que cet effort va
s'adresser à ceux qui autrement n'ont
pas d'autres solutions disponibles pour
leurs enfants
je trouve que c'est un choix très
important
[Applaudissements]
et puis une politique sociale ça
commence pour lutter contre ces
déterminismes où ces contraintes ou
seppois qui viennent de l'origine d'où
l'on vient
ça commence par l'éducation c'est
pourquoi j'ai été extrêmement heureux
que jean michel blanquer reviennent et à
notre université de rentrée et à notre
congrès au nom du même principe
si l'on veut que les enfants ou que les
jeunes se trouve libéré de cette
injustice qui leur tombent dessus sans
que évidemment ni eux ni leurs parents
soit pour rien dans cette mauvaise
distribution des cartes ou des atouts
alors il faut que l'école leur apporte
ce qu'il ne pourrait pas trouver
ailleurs
est ce qu'il n'est pas trouver ailleurs
par donges ceux qui ne pourraient pas
trouver ailleurs
je vais le dire sans esprit corporatiste
la première chose que l'école doit
apporter c'est la maîtrise de la langue
parce que
[Applaudissements]
la langue c'est pas une discipline comme
les autres ta langue française
l'expression écrite et orale la
réflexion le la capacité à dire y
compris à dire par son corps les
comédiens savent pas très bien la
capacité à traduire ce qu'on sent se
compensent ces deux choses qui sont
essentiels l'une et l'autre la première
c'est qu'on vous donne accès au pouvoir
réel
vous avez un interlocuteur dans une
administration
il entend à la première seconde
sans même aucune présentation qui est en
face de lui il sait qu'elle est celle ou
celui qui s'adresse à lui
et cette puissance d'affirmations
l'école devrait l'offrir ça c'est la
première chose est la première nécessité
et la deuxième nécessité ou en tout cas
l'heure le deuxième conséquence c'est
que ça permet de lutter contre la
violence notamment la violence dans les
cours de récréation notamment la
violence dans les cités parce qu'il se
trouve que la violence est assez souvent
l'expression d'une impuissance
insupportable on a au fond de soi même
quelque chose qui bouge
une volonté de faire sentir quelque
chose alors on y va à coup de poing
et le jour où l'on apprendra à traduire
ses sentiments là on désamorce ou d'une
certaine manière la violence et donc la
langue la culture générale on est dans
un monde où internet offrent tous toutes
les bibliothèques de la planète toutes
les connaissances de la planète tout
simplement
il y en a qui savent se repérer dans
cette jungle et d'autres qui sont pas
capables de se repérer dans cette jungle
et c'est une extraordinaire inégalités
et donc je soutiens la politique qui à
l'école veut revenir aux fondamentaux à
la transmission de la langue de tout ce
qui peut permettre de maîtriser la
langue au nom au nombre duquel je range
les humanités et la culture générale qui
est la boussole et la carte pour se
retrouver dans la jungle du monde
mais l'éducation projet social
l'éducation ça doit pas s'arrêter à
l'école et au plus jeune âge l'éducation
tout au long de la vie devrait être une
obsession des gouvernements du 21e
siècle et je voudrais que ce fut une
obsession du gouvernement de la france
et des gouvernements européens
aujourd'hui
alors c'est très c'est très évident pour
tout ce qui touche à la formation
professionnelle
des dizaines de milliards qui sont
mobilisés chaque année sans qu'on ait la
certitude qu'il s'adresse à ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin et notamment sans
connaît la certitude qu'il s'adresse à
ceux qui au chômage un an le plus besoin
et donc la réforme de la formation
professionnelle qui va être portée est
évidemment un pas décisif dans cette
formation tout au long de la vie mais je
veux aller plus loin j'ai toujours été
fasciné par la formation des états unis
au début du 20e siècle
la formation des états unis pays où où
tant de 10 millions venaient nourrir le
tissu américain elle s'est fondée pour
une très grande part sur une réalité à
laquelle je voudrais qu'on réfléchisse
dans le projet social français qui est
l'école du soir le l'idée que tout le
monde
où qu'il soit peut trouver la formation
dont il aura envie pour sa vie
professionnelle pour sa maîtrise de la
langue du pays ou pour son
épanouissement personnel et il se trouve
qu'en 2017 nous sommes au temps où ce
rêve qui a fait les états unis est
possible chez nous pourquoi pas ce qu'il
y a ces instruments nouveaux ces outils
nouveaux qu'on appelle c'est un terme
barbare anglo saxons qu'on appelle les
mous
massive open online cause les cours
offerts par internet avec les plus
grands professeurs de la planète qu'il
est un peu ardu de découvrir tout seul
mais qu'une société moderne devrait
permirent devrait permettre de découvrir
à tous ceux qui en ont besoin
en ajoutant à ces instruments universels
des moniteurs de proximité qui
pourraient guider l'encore dans la
richesse des offres ou dans la jungle
des offres
je trouve que dans la formation dans
l'école tout au long de la vie il ya là
quelque chose qui ouvre un horizon à
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas je vais ajouter
une ou deux autres idées sur ce que le
projet social pourrait être non fondées
sur les allocations
il ya quelque chose qui m'a toujours
profondément dérangé comme maire ou
comme élu de proximité c'est que toute
la solidarité
elle est incitatrice où elle porte à la
solitude
or je considère mes z'amis debout savent
que que nous sommes en train de préparer
un grand plan anti solitude pour la
ville ce que la ville c'est le lieu où
on devrait être le moins seuls et en
réalité c'est assez souvent le lieu où
l'on est le plus seul
y compris à ne pas connaître son voisin
de palier et donc nous nous estimons que
c'est le devoir d'une cité que de
proposer un grand plan anti solitude
pour tous les milieux sociaux et pour
tous les âges
parce que les collégiens de la ville de
pau viennent d'avoir le
le prix national avec un film qu'ils ont
produit sur le harcèlement pour raconter
ce que le harcèlement et dans la cour de
récréation et parfois ça conduit au
suicide
le harcèlement c'est de la solitude
le jeune qui entre à l'université et qui
n'est pas extravertie qui n'aime pas
faire la fête ou ne sait pas faire la
fête ou n'osent pas faire la fête ou
bien qu'ils découvrent le mathy des
formations et comment on doit étudier à
l'université là aussi c'est de la
solitude
la jeune mère de famille qui a deux
enfants et qui peut pas sortir le soir
parce qu'elles gagnent pas assez une
rencontre personne c'est de la solide
quand on avance en âge
ceux qui sont frappés par le veuvage
femme ou homme il se retrouve tout seul
parce que les êtres humains c'est comme
ça ça ne va pas spontanément vers qui
connaît le malheur c'est de la solitude
et quand on avance en âge au moment où
la retraite il ya beaucoup de gens qui
perdent la vie sociale pas tous bien sûr
les quelques-uns
et puis le grand âge aussi donc toutes
les générations sont frappés par la
solitude et moi ce qui m'a toujours
frappé c'est que l'état par la puissance
publique sociale etc et est incitatif
incitateurs à la solitude
par exemple vous êtes tout seul
vous avez une allocation logement et un
certain nombre de minima sociaux minimum
qui est yes vous avez quelqu'un un ami
un copain avec qui vous pourriez vous
installez parce que 800 euros tout seul
c'est la misère mais 800 euros quand on
est deux ça fait 1600 euros et 800 euros
quand on est trois ça fait 2000 400
euros et c'est une famille qui devrait
pouvoir vivre parce qu on se répartit
les charges et les obligations mais
à l'instant vous installer avec
quelqu'un vous perdez vos allocations
je dis que c'est un gâchis et 7
une blessure que nous devrions corriger
il faut imaginer une incitation dans les
politiques publiques à ce que les êtres
humains se retrouvent pour partager le
destin que la vie leur a offert
[Applaudissements]
toujours projet social puis je vais
m'arrêter là parce qu'on pourrait
égrener d'autres idées ça va être
l'objet de la réflexion qui est la nôtre
je considère comme infiniment
progressiste et méritant d'être soutenu
dans le projet qu emmanuel macron à
proposer aux français je considère que
l'idée de la deuxième chance
vous avez raté quelque chose eh bien on
vous dit mon vieux l'histoire n'est pas
finie
c'est pas parce que tu as raté quelque
chose qu'on va en tenir rigueur toute la
vie c'est pas parce que tu as fait une
bêtise qu'on va te mettre toute ta vie à
l'écart c'est pas parce que quelque
chose s'est cassé à un moment qu'on ne
va pas aider à saisir une autre chance
la deuxième chance
alors vous voyez tout ce que ça veut
dire du point de vue juridique
du point de vue aussi des juridictions
ce que ça veut dire pour le futur la
deuxième chance et même la troisième
chanson a besoin d'une troisième chance
c'est infiniment progressistes c'est un
projet infiniment social ça ne demande
pas d'allocations mais ça libère et ça
permet de voir l'avenir différemment
voilà des idées pour le projet social du
pays
et vous voyez toute la démonstration que
j'ai essayé de faire devant vous elle a
une signification profonde
ça n'est pas parce qu'il n'y a plus ou
qu'il y a moins d'argent public que la
porte est fermée à un projet social pour
la france est exactement le contraire
nous savons qu'il n'y aura plus d'argent
ou pas autant d'argent public qu'on le
voudrait ou qu on le pourrait mais je
pense que ça doit déclencher
l'imagination de ceux qui sont
profondément acquis un projet social
pour le pays je vais finir cet exposé
sur une nécessité c'est que nous
bâtissions non seulement le projet
économique le projet social mais le
projet démocratique pour la france et
vous voyez naturellement ont conduit
cette idée là nous avons rendu vie à la
perspective d'un centre indépendant et
d'une majorité centrale pour le pays
qu'est ce que c'est que le centre bon
c'est une chose très simple jean louis
l'a rappelé hier en quatre idées
lapidaire je vais n'en retenir qu'une
seule le centre c'est la reconnaissance
du pluralisme dans la démocratie
le sens a dit une chose vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'être d'un côté ou de l'autre
spécialement quand les deux côtés se
trompent vous avez la liberté d'affirmer
un autre chemin une autre voie d'autres
convictions et parce que vous refusez
cette contrainte ou cette suggestion
d'être d'un côté ou de l'autre du même
moment du même mouvement
vous libérer tous ceux qui sont
inconfortables
insatisfait qui n'acceptent pas que leur
camp leur impose des idées qui ne sont
pas les leurs nous sommes la garantie du
pluralisme
nous sommes la garantie du pluralisme
pour nous et dieu sait que nous n'avons
pas l'intention de baisser pavillon sur
ce point mais nous sommes la garantie du
pluralisme pour les autres en même temps
parce que nous considérons que le
pluralisme est une richesse
moi je ne suis pas choqué qui est des
gens de gauche à gauche je suis pas
choqué qui est des gens de droite à
droite
je me suis toujours battu simplement
contre l'idée que le centre et la droite
c'était la même chose
personne n'ayant jamais soutenu que le
centre et la gauche c'était la même
chose mais ce que on aurait pu et je me
serais battu de la même manière mais
ceux qui soutenaient que le centre et la
droite c'était la même chose vous savez
le parti unique de la droite et du
centre avec des traits d'union entre
chacun de ses mots c'est les traits
d'union qui sont mon ennemi le centre a
sa logique sa vision sa philosophie son
histoire son projet et c'est bien pour
tout le monde et si la droite à son
projet si la droite à sa vision si la
droite à son affirmation
ça ne me surprend pas et la gauche
pareil j'ai toujours soutenu une maxime
qui a souvent fait rire et que je prends
considèrent au contraire comme
absolument juste c'est les partis se
tiennent par le noyau dur
et si vous réfléchissez à cette maxime
alors vous apercevrez que la vie
politique française l'a constamment
vérifier et donc si l'on veut qu'il y
ait un centre il faut un noyau dur du
centre parce que contrairement à ce
qu'un certain nombre de gens vous disent
le centre c'est pas vous le centre c'est
dur enfin ça doit être
ne croyez pas que ce soit une idée
provocatrice c'est la réalité même de la
démocratie quand elle est vivante en
france en europe
voyez ce que j'ai en tête en france en
europe et c'est une nécessité
et si c'est une nécessité alors ça veut
dire qu'il y ait qu il doit y avoir des
institutions pour que ce pluralisme là
soient vivants et en bonne santé et la
promesse qu emmanuel macron à fait aux
français c'est que précisément il allait
garantir que le pluralisme puisse
s'exprimer dans notre vie publique en
particulier par la re légitimation des
assemblées c'est à dire la diminution du
nombre de leurs membres
ce qui est un engagement qui a été pris
et par l'introduction d'un mode d'une
loi électorale qui garantissent un mode
de scrutin juste c'est-à-dire
proportionnelle c'est à dire où chacune
des forces du pays aura désormais la
légitimité de se faire reconnaître pour
ce qu'elle est une voie c'est une voix
et une voix donne les mêmes droits à
quelques courants politiques que ce soit
ça va être un excusez moi vous auriez dû
applaudir j'aurais pu rire j'aurais pu
boire rien donc boire
la fièvre de saisie et donc le ce combat
là car si je me trompe pas ça va être un
combat très important pour le
rétablissement d'une vie démocratique
normale dans laquelle chacun des
citoyens aura sa place pour ce qu'il est
j'ai souvent dit à quoi servait-il de
voter à gauche à neuilly ou à droite à
saint denis
c'était pas des citoyens de deuxième
zone
mais c'est des citoyens à qui la vie
publique ne reconnaissait pas leur place
à qui la vie publique ne reconnaissez
pas leurs droits et je m'adressais aux
deux parties du monopole qui exerçait le
pouvoir
alternativement depuis des décennies et
je leur disais mais qui êtes vous pour
refuser le droit de vote
c'est à dire le droit d'être représentés
à des gens simplement parce qu'ils
pensent pas comme vous nous avons rompu
avec cette malédiction
nous avons brisé cette malédiction et
nous allons dans les mois qui viennent
combat très difficile faire passer dans
la loi en tout cas nous ferons tout pour
ça ces engagements
cette vision que le président de la
république a défendu devant le p dernier
point et je m'arrêterai là deux phrases
nous avons reconstruit rétabli la
possibilité pour notre pays d'une
majorité cohérente centrale maintenant
il faut l'organiser
chacun doit s'organiser pour soi même et
naturellement en marche se trouve que
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour la
démarche de hull en marche
est ce qu'ils vont essayer de la faire
vivre pourquoi vous faire une confidence
parce que nous avons essayé la même
démarche d'ouvrir largement a des
origines politiques des sensibilités
différentes pour construire un parti de
transformation de la société
ça va essayer en 2007 avec le même
impact et les mêmes difficultés
donc ça n'est pas moins qu'ils
regarderai ça de loin
au contraire si je peux aider j'aiderai
si nous pouvons aider nous aiderons ne
serait ce que par les meilleures
relations possibles que nous devons
avoir sur le terrain avec les
représentants de ce mouvement
il demeure que nous avons le devoir de
nous organiser
chacun pour notre compte mais aussi
ensemble et cet ensemble cette maison
commune comme jeudi pour rendre plus
solides
la démarche de ceux qui défendent la
majorité centrale pour préparer les
élections
accessoirement mais pas uniquement hier
des amis journalistes me disais mais au
fond vous voulez cette organisation pour
les européennes ou pour les municipales
qui viennent non nous voulons cette
organisation parce que nous voulons que
ce grand courant qui porte aujourd'hui
la politique est l'avenir du pays
ils soient vivants efforts et enraciner
pour des décennies pour les décennies
qui viennent pour l'avenir de la france
et ainsi si nous avons une claire
conscience de ce qui a changé
si nous avons une idée nette du projet
que nous devons porter pour le pays
si l'on comprend que les trois grands
chapitres projets économiques et de
vitalité projet social de nouvelles
solidarités et de nouvelles attentions
et d'émancipation du plus grand nombre
possible de ceux qui forment avec nous
la société projet démocratique pour que
le pluralisme
il trouve sa place alors nous aurons
durablement changer non seulement la vie
politique
mais le visage de la france nous aurons
rempli notre vocation
merci de votre présence et de votre
amitié
[Applaudissements]
je suis fâché
ce jeu
obama
et contre nous de la tyrannie les
rassemblant des données l'état
rassemblant des entendez-vous dans nos
campagnes de ceux qui viennent jusqu'à
un bras égorger nos fils et nos
compagnes aux citoyens
corey bataillons marchons
car voilà c'est sur cette main c est ce
que ça cher ce congrès du modem son
président françois bayrou qui a
développé son projet dans un discours de
plus d'une heure nous allons y revenir
avec nos trois invités toujours présents
sur ce plateau anita auxerre rebonjour
éditorialistes y atlantico le
politologue olivier rouquan bonjour
olivier notre éditorialiste ludovic faut
alors ludovic un françois bayrou qui a
fait un long discours je le disais 1h15
de discours discours dans lequel il a
longuement développé son projet social
et son projet économique les ans ludovic
oui alors longuement développées
effectivement même si concrètement on
reste un peu sur notre faim parce que
c'est vrai que ces dernières semaines
aussi bien pendant les discussions
budgétaires où françois bayrou avait un
peu critiqué en creux la réforme de
l'isf f voulue par emmanuel macron il
avait invité le président à développer
justement un projet social pour pour la
france hélas aujourd'hui françois bayrou
a fait entendre cette tonalité
alors il a dit avec un projet social ça
ne se résumait pas à un projet de
location
certes parce que françois bayrou est
dans l'idée qu' il y à il y aura sans
doute de moins en moins d'argent public
pour pour les allocations mais ça
manquait en revanche de propositions il
a dit le social ça commençait à l'école
pour réduire les inégalités il a parlé
aussi de la nécessité de lutter contre
contre la solitude mais on reste un peu
sur notre faim sur les propositions
concrètes on était plus dans la
philosophie politique que dans vraiment
des mesures à mettre sur la table c'est
aussi va travailler olivier ça manquait
de concret ce discours de françois
bayrou
oui mais cela correspond à ce que nous
faisions tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
la voie est tellement étroites
finalement que là on est presque sur
l'illustration de la théorique
le sandre c'est un espace vide parfois à
se dire que ce discours
bon on a ressassé un certain nombre de
thèmes mais si vous voulez il n'y a pas
de propositions concrètes y compris
lorsqu on dénonce les inégalités dans le
monde et donc la place de la
financiarisation de l'économie où le
poids des des majors de l'internet ont
que faire pour essayer de réguler les
choses ya rien il n'y a pas la moindre
proposition donc il voulait là on est
vraiment sûr sur le dilemme pour le
modem c'est d'exister d'arriver à
comment dire force et j'allais presque
dire parfois la république en marche a
changé un peu de braquer b sauf que pour
l'instant au delà de l'affirmation il
n'y a pas la démonstration de fait la
seule proposition concrète elle concerne
les institutions mais pour ce qui est du
projet social il a répété à deux fois
que c'est pas parce qu'il ya moins
d'argent qu'il n'y a pas de politique
sociale moi je voudrais bien qu'il
explique comment on va faire et enfin
c'est du moins ce que c'est ce qu'essaye
de faire le gouvernement
et quand il dit que la bce devrait avoir
pour responsabilité la gestion des
monnaies pour obtenir le plein emploi
ça laisse un peu dubitatif quand même la
tonalité il est plus dans le pacte
majoritaire très clairement aujourd'hui
françois bayrou on se posait la question
avant son discours il est plus dans le
dans le pacte majoritaire que dans la
différenciation et d'une certaine façon
il semble presque en avoir pris son
parti
un petit mot avant de revenir sur ce
pacte majoritaire et sa relation avec la
république en mars sur la réforme des
institutions dont parlait à l'instant
anita c'était ça la deuxième partie de
son discours son fameux projet
démocratique y la défense et une réforme
importante pour françois bayrou un cette
réforme institutionnelle à venir oui il
a même rappelé pour le couler les
engagements des manades macron / / /
skate emmanuel macron a fait depuis six
sept mois finalement il a expliqué que
le projet d' emmanuel macron c'était
aussi le sien et vice versa et donc il
est en quelque sorte donné au delà des
petites différences 1 sur lle cesse
notamment il a quelque sorte donné
quitus au gouvernement de ce qui a été
fait jusque là en revanche effectivement
sur la la réforme des institutions on
voit bien que là il est il est très
attentif parce que c'est l'existence
même niveau c'était l'une des conditions
de son soutient emmanuel macron et ses
lunes
des conditions de la poursuite de la
renaissance finalement du modem et
notamment cette question de la
proportionnelle c'est la chose sur
laquelle il a été plus concret
effectivement elle est composée françois
bayrou mais dans quel sens la
proportionnelle bon on a bien compris ça
fait des décennies que les centristes de
toutes obédiences veulent de la
proportionnelle ils sont pas les seuls
très bien simplement les institutions et
la réforme c'est la justice la place de
l'indépendance du parquet il ya vraiment
du contenu y compris d'ailleurs sur la
question finalement de la démocratie et
du pluralisme il y aurait des choses à
dire à l'assemblée nationale on en
discute depuis quelques semaines
maintenant d'une réforme de bon voilà ce
n'était pas un discours qui disait à
comment dire à donner du corps du
contenu à un projet spécifiquement modem
s'était c'est assez surprenant qu passe
quand il parle d' organiser la majorité
ne dit pas comment il n'est ce pas il
ans d'aider des idées des pros mais il
n'y a pas de contenu concret on a bien
senti que françois bayrou finalement été
assez content satisfait même d'être là
où il en est aujourd'hui c'est à dire il
ya un an le modem ne peser rien et pas
des plus de députés il y avait
aujourd'hui il ya 47 députés françois
bayrou fait partie du comité de pilotage
de la majorité et on a bien senti
pendant la première de première
demi-heure de son discours finalement
qu'il prenait assez largement sa part de
la victoire d'emmanuel macron et donc il
se contente pour l'instant de cette
résurrection du modem peut être avec la
volonté de poser dans le de peser dans
le futur mais on sent bien qu'il est
aussi même s'il n'en a pas dit un mot
dans la préparation des prochaines
échéances électorales européennes et
municipales et il sait que le modem ne
pourra poursuivre sa renaissance
finalement que dans une alliance avec la
république en marche et donc il reste
finalement assez assez collé à son
partenaire de la majorité il a
d'ailleurs longuement on va juste
écouter françois bayrou avant de vous
entendre les vire au camp puisqu'il a
longuement parlé d' emmanuel macron
longuement parlé à d'edouard philippe
par le premier ministre qui était
présent hier au congrès du modem je vous
propose de re écoutez un extrait de
discours françois bayrou nous avons
vérifié que edouard philippe
avec ses idées ses convictions sa
liberté d'esprit lui aussi l'a montré
puis son style manière d'être parce que
moi je croise avait une vieille
expression française qui dès le style
c'est l'homme un style c'est la
politique aussi une manière non
agressive et non du peu non agressive et
en même temps pas dupes de ce que porte
avec l'humour qui fait qu'on se met en
question soi même et avec l'ironie qu'il
faut quand on veut mordre
et bien tout ça cette manière de mener
l'équipe gouvernementale tout ça répond
à la promesse implicite qui était celle
de la compagne d'emmanuelle macron et
pour nous c'est une fierté de soutenir
et de participer olivier c'est vrai
qu'il a longuement - tout au moins
pendant le début de son discours vantait
les mérites des manuels macron vantait
les mérites des doors philippe françois
bayrou oui il est tout à fait dans ya
une impossibilité de choix en fait ce
leader aujourd'hui et dans le soutien il
le dit il assume il ne peut pas faire
autrement en fait et c'est ce qui est
assez étonnant et est remarquable pour
un personnage politique qui a passé les
15 dernières années de sa vie politique
a défié parfois des pouvoirs assez
puissant mais là c'est terminé
et ensuite il ya et c'était assez
remarquable est paradoxal lorsque ce
mouvement qui se veut démocratique
pluraliste et d'insister là dessus
finalement sur le style présidentiel
fait l'éloge d'un pouvoir très verticale
très jacobin voir que certains
qualifient de bonapartiste parfois donc
des centristes qui aujourd'hui apprécié
ce style présidentiel c'est nouveau on
va tout de suite prendre la direction du
14ème arrondissement de paris où se
tient ce congrès du modem retrouvèrent à
bika habits vous êtes en compagnie de la
ministre auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur jacqueline gourault oui oui
on revienne je suis avec ma
nous avons très social quelles garanties
demandées vous à la majorité dans la
suite du quinquennat
nous demandons pas des garanties nous
exprimons ce qui est notre sensibilité
et notamment j'ai beaucoup aimé tout le
passage de françois bayrou sur
l'émancipation et aussi la manière dont
il a écrit la libération au fond des
systèmes c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple il a expliqué quand il y a des
minimums des minimums pardon sociaux et
que vous trouvez un travail qui pourrait
compenser vos minimes au minimum je vais
y arriver sociaux mais ce n'est pas
possible c'est comme quand vous avez des
soutiens au logement et que vous vous
mettez avec quelqu'un vous perdez la
politique sociale c'est la libération
d'un certain nombre
comment dire de tak et qui empêche les
gens d'améliorer leur situation et qui
permette l'émancipation
françois bayrou avait appelé récemment
emmanuel macron en tout cas faire une
vraie réforme sociale est ce que le
modem se veut l'ailé gauche de la
majorité
pas du tout nous sommes au centre on va
pas recommencer à faire de la droite et
de la gauche au centre nous sommes des
centristes
nous avons des valeurs des convictions
que nous exprimons et qui sont bien sûr
partagé par en marché par le président
emmanuel macron si nous l'avons rejoint
dans une alliance et qui le défendent et
les idées qui étaient les nôtres sur la
question européenne hier christophe
castaner a appelé à une grande alliance
avec une liste ouverte
est ce que en tout cas c'est ce qu'il
faut faire parce je crois qu'il faut
rassembler tous les européens évidemment
tous ceux qui se battent pour une
amélioration de l'europe et on sait
comment des personnalités aussi
différentes que françois bayrou
alain juppé est aujourd'hui le président
de la république par son discours
extraordinaire à la sorbonne sont les
promoteurs de cette europe renouvelé
merci madame la ministre
merci beaucoup a dit on vous retrouve
tout à l'heure pour d'autres réactions
alors on entend déjà qu'une gourde
parlais à l'instant de cet axe central
c'est vrai qu'il en a longuement parlé
pendant son discours françois bayrou cet
axe central cette seule majorité
cohérente possible finalement at il dit
oui mais c'est le sait le triomphe de la
stratégie de françois bayrou depuis
depuis 2002 même si ce n'est pas lui qui
a porté cette stratégie au pouvoir c'est
emmanuel macron et c'est pour ça que
françois bayrou est finalement assez
satisfait de la situation actuelle c'est
à dire que sa stratégie l'a emporté le
modem qui était en état de mort clinique
il ya un an
aujourd'hui retrouver une place dans le
paysage politique français et françois
bayrou estime qu'il a appelé il ya
quelques temps
françois bayrou a finalement à la
création d'une maison commune alors sans
dire très concrètement quelle forme ça
pourrait prendre une maison commune
entre la république anglais et le modem
alors non pas tout à fait parce que on
voit bien que dans son esprit ce serait
plus plus qu'une fusion ce serait une
sorte de confédération qui pourrait
notamment prendre forme au moment des
élections et en particulier des
élections européennes parce qu'il est
clair que notamment sur les européennes
mais c'est aussi vrai assez largement au
delà des quelques petites différences
sur l'europe en particulier il n'y a pas
une feuille de papier à cigarette entre
ce que pense et ce que veut emmanuel
macron est ce que pense et ce que veut
françois bayrou on va écouter injuste ce
qu'en disait françois bayrou il ya
quelques minutes de cet axe central et
on en débat juste après
les autres qui nous disaient mais il
faut une majorité ou de droite ou de
gauche pour qu'elle soit cohérente
en réalité ils mentent et ils savent
ugly eux mêmes pour les plus honnêtes où
il essayait de nous aveugler pour les
autres parce que les deux majorités
latéral on a vérifié dix fois depuis 20
ans qu'elle était totalement incohérente
fracturé qu'elles étaient entre les
extrêmes de chaque camp et les modérés
de chaque thon pas d'unité à droite pas
de cohérence à droite
pas d'unité à gauche pas de cohérence à
gauche il n'y avait qu'une cohérence
possible
c'était la grande majorité centrale
l'arc central comme nous disions que
nous avons finalement imposé dans la vie
politique du pays
elle tient certes la taxe contrat que
nous avons imposées elles il n'y a pas
d'unité au centre non plus il faudra
quand même le rappeler qu'il ya une
contradiction dans le propos de françois
bayrou quand il parle de la liberté
d'affirmer un autre chemin c'est à dire
le sien et le désir d'appartenir à la
maison comme eu à la majorité sans
vraiment se distinguer et sans expliquer
quelles sont les différences c'est il ya
quelque chose qui ne colle pas dans son
discours oui et puis il ya des choses
c'est aussi c'est bon la démocratie sa
vie aussi par l'alternance
or quand vous avez un centrisme dominant
ans ça va nous rappeler la démocratie
chrétienne italienne mais il n'y a
jamais eu d'alternance pendant plusieurs
dizaines d'années donc le modèle qui est
proposé c'est un changement de vie
politique majeur voire peut-être de
régimes politiques quelque part sans
dire qui se profile parce que lorsqu'il
n'y a pas d'opposition en mesure de
alterné au pouvoir
finalement quel est le poids des
électeurs et en plus si on utilise
beaucoup de proportionnelle on sait que
je crois finalement diminue donc il ya
quand même un nom a écrasé la droite et
la gauche et le deuxième essai ce dans
tous les cas c'est selon
ça donc ils verts rêvent mais ça pose un
vrai problème sur la définition qu'on a
de la démocratie est le deuxième point
que remarquable c'est à las trois de
gauche qui a priori était soi-disant
insignifiant se substituerait un clivage
en cours de construction centriste
raisonnable et raisonné fait pour
exercer le pouvoir contre ce que l'on
appelle le populisme simplement on voit
aujourd'hui qu'ailleurs en europe si
alternance il ya cela n'est pas sans
risque on va retourner un sur le lieu du
congrès du modem dans le 14e
arrondissement pour une autre réaction
celle du patron du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale marc fesneau à
votre micro rabhi bonjour monsieur
fesneau bonjour vous accuse
régulièrement en tout cas de ne pas
peser au sein de la majorité
comment est-ce que vous marquez comment
est ce que vous arrivez à exister au
sein de cette écrasante majorité en
marche
simplement en étant nous-mêmes et
emportant les propositions qui sont les
nôtres sans une volonté distinction pour
la distinction enfin l'opposition qu'il
toute l'opposition ne disent pas parce
que je crois qu'une partie de
l'opposition voient aussi le travail que
nous effectuons pour l air pour alerter
sidi l'opposition malheureusement pense
pour un certain nombre de ses membres
qu'elle est là simplement pour se poser
donc on propose on propose des
abonnements en amont des textes on
travaille avec le gouvernement
on n'est pas là portait un drapeau en
lisant cet article là il est le fruit
d'une âpre négociation est gay c'est ce
qu'on appelle tous à faut qu'on soit
capable de se parler de palme être
forcément sur la place publique
d'alertés sur des choses que le
gouvernement puisse évoluer plus qu'on
puisse avoir des débats l'assemblée
nationale j'allais dire quelque chose
d'assez simple on fait notre travail de
parlementaire et alors sur la question
des européennes christophe castaner hier
a appelé à un grand rassemblement est ce
que vous êtes favorable oui je salue le
discours de christophe castaner sur cet
aspect sur les autres nous avons besoin
que se rassemblent ce qu'ils pensent la
même chose sur l'europe comme nous
l'avons fait sur le champ national et
donc je trouve que cette proposition est
cette idée que nous partageons avec lui
est une bonne idée merci beaucoup
monsieur fesneau merci beaucoup au ras
aby très rapidement un résultat on a
entendu un françois bayrou pendant plus
d'une heure qu'est ce qu'il peut espérer
françois bayrou encore aujourd'hui mais
je veux me le monde parce que le seul
moment où le centre a vraiment pesé dans
la vème république c'était entre 1988 et
1993 lorsque la majorité socialiste
était relative et qu'il fallait la
pointe centristes pour faire passer les
projets
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs que la csg a
été voté à l'époque grâce au lobbying de
michel rocard pour qu un certain nombre
de députés centristes ne veut pas la
censure
à propos de la csg parce qu'elle avait
été adoptée par défaut pardon puisqu'il
y avait une motion de censure
mais aujourd'hui le poids du centre je
ne le vois pas merci beaucoup merci
anita merci olivier rouquan merci
ludovic d'avoir été sur ce plateau pour
suivre et analyser avec nous ce discours
de françois bayrou merci arabica qui
étaient sur place pour recueillir les
réactions politiques merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis et très bonne journée
sur les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]